ich habe mir bereits Mystery Boxen auf
Ebay für 50 € 100 €, 500 € und 600 €
bestellt aber heute toppen wir alles
denn meine
1000 € ebay Mystery Box kann man und ich
meine gebt euch mal wie riesig dieses
Paket ist ich würde sagen wir nehmen
jetzt mal direkt Katharina
wegen Kater
und machen jetzt erstmal die Box auf
was ist Wenko produziert
badezimmerzubehör
ihr seht gleich was in diesem Paket drin
ist
[Musik]
Traktor Kalender 2024
hier sind einfach
[Musik]
allerdings war das allererste was oben
in den Paket drin lag ja diese Wenko
Verpackung und während ich das ganze
gerade mal aufmachen kann ich ja allen
unter euch die eventuell gar keine
Ahnung haben was ebay Mystery Boxen
überhaupt sind ja mal eben kurz erklären
was ich mir überhaupt bestellt habe denn
man kann bei Ebay nicht nur normale
Produkte bestellen sondern auch einfach
sagen hey ich
sag jetzt nicht das ist ein Klodeckel
ich habe einen
ich habe einen Klodeckel
ich habe einen Klodeckel gekauft
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
sind im Grunde genommen einfach
irgendwelche Überraschungsboxen wo du
keine Ahnung hast was ich darin befinden
wird meistens ist es allerdings so dass
wenn du halt eine Box für 100 € kaufst
oder 200 € oder 500 € oder wie in diesem
Falle für 1000
dass der Inhalt der Box in etwa diese
monetären Gegenwert entspricht
und dann hat man halt random Sachen drin
wie beispielsweise fischadiletten oder
ein Toilettendeckel mit Blumen Optik ich
würde allerdings sagen wir schauen mal
weiter was ich hier noch so drin
befindet denn das was ich auch direkt
sehe ist
pure Drink SmartPad drinking Foundation
also
ein Trinkwasserbrunnen für Haustiere
ich habe keine Haustiere das nächste
Produkt dass ich in unserer Box hier
befindet ist ein
ich kriege keine Luft
ich weiß nicht was das sein soll aber
auf jeden Fall auch noch so eine
komische Pumpe mit dabei da ich
allerdings gerade da drin schon kein
Sauerstoff bekommen habe wer mir glaube
ich nur noch schlechter geworden wenn
ich dann auch noch so ekelhafte Plastik
Luft ins Gesicht bekommen hätte aber gut
wir machen weiter mit der Box und im
nächsten Paket was ich hier drin
befindet denn es ist das hier
nein
[Musik]
das ist nicht wahr es ist ein bisschen
leicht deswegen kann es sein dass es
eine harte Verarsche ist das für
komische Pokémon Alter
ich bin gerade bisschen sprachlos
bisher hatten die ganzen Sachen von 200
€ allein diese komische Pumpe hier für
irgendwelche Tiere die sieht richtig
teuer aus die ist auch richtig schwer
und hochwertig aber
ich habe mir wieder gedacht ich werde
hier nur gescannt weil das ist das
sechste Box Video was ich gemacht habe
jetzt und ich habe noch nie irgendwas
krasses drin gehabt jetzt habe ich in
der Switch
ich mache jetzt mal kurz auf
die geht an
oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott wir haben zwei
funktionierende Controller
wir haben ein funktioniert wir haben
eine Pokémon designte dockt Anschluss
nicht besser als meine ich allerdings
schon eine Switch habe kann ich
logischerweise hier mit nichts anfangen
deswegen habe ich mir gerade mal so
gedacht könnte ich das Ding an Euch
verlosen
ich will raus jetzt allerdings kein
typisches influencer Gewinnspiel machen
von Wegen folgt diesen 1000 Personen die
niemand kennt und dann habt ihr eine
Chance zu gewinnen sondern ich würde
sagen wir machen das ganz easy like
einfach mein neues Instagram Bild und
kommentiert Nintendo switch
dann
nimmt er daran teil
das ist für mich dann am einfachsten das
rauszufinden weil es gibt Website wo man
dann einfach die Kommentare durch
filtern kann und zufällig auswählen wer
gewonnen hat deswegen
machen wir es einfach so habe ich jetzt
zwar nichts von aber beschweren kann ich
mich dann normalerweise eher weniger
allerdings sagen dass wir weitermachen
mit dem nächsten Produkt das hier unsere
1000 € über Mystery Box befindet denn
das ist meine Damen und
en ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist
aber es ist irgendwas für ein Gerät da
ich exakt einmal im Jahr drinne
wenn ihr das gewinnen wollt dann als
nächstes haben wir hier drin eine
[Musik]
Glühbirne
oh mein Gott nein
nein
das ist keine Glühbirne
das sind zwei Glühbirnen
das kann ich nicht zeigen
das ist
Aldi Marke kennen wissen glaube ich
Bescheid ein paar Sekunden später
oh nein
da ist gar nicht
xxxxxxxxxxl mit bei
ein FC Schalke 04 Brillenetui
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
Produkt meine lieben Freunde und zwar
ist es ein HDMI Kabel
deppi
ich kenne mich mit Technik aus dann
haben wir auch noch 28
Fortnite v-bucks für 20 Euro
oh perfekt der kurdischen abgehoben das
heißt es ist wahrscheinlich überhaupt
nichts mehr wert diese Lego Duplo Box
war auf jeden Fall noch mit dabei
irgendwas mit Giraffen und Elefanten
wenn ich irgendwann Kind habe 40 Freund
hierüber wird sich das Kind
wahrscheinlich nicht so freuen denn das
sind ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist
das was sechsmal dorfstopper
aber das sind ja keine Türstopper die
sind ja
die sind ja hart
wir machen weiter mit der nächsten Sache
und zwar einer sports and travel Tower
Minecraft timer
das ist einfach eine Handtuch oder wie
[Applaus]
und das letzte Produkt in das stimmt gar
nicht einmal haben wir noch Panasonic
advanced lonelasting energy AAA
Batterien
ich muss tatsächlich auch mal AAA und
das letzte Produkt ist ein permanent
right flower
getrocknetes Pampers Gras
ja meine Damen und Herren an der